ce qu'elle avait fait tout content
d'avoir vu le gilet jaune au plus on
appelait 7,20 à la pub du coulage et
répété c'est ça m'a mis un merci mamie
en tout cas très beau trou au mail va
vous être très belle en bouquet
magnifique
alors on a plein de trucs aujourd'hui
notamment le premier s'étant que je fête
mon anniversaire c'est la norme
aujourd'hui on est vraiment je crois que
j'ai un peu survendu le truc je fête mon
anniversaire par bio pain ça aujourd'hui
à ben du coup je vais te dire déjà tapas
et la photo de ouais merci
et bien justement pour l'occasion cyril
j'ai décidé de faire un petit film de
nos meilleurs moments de complicité que
c'est vrai ouais mais malin
malheureusement je vous rassure enfin
sur le sur le format du film on est plus
sur un snap que sur un long métrage et
je vois que vous avez tout de suite
intégré mon prénom ça ça fait plaisir
d'accueillir à andreas comme tous les
soirs il revient sur tout ce qui s'est
passé et tout de suite hier au grillage
ce qui va nous faire tout ce qui s'est
passé a intéressé par timo nationale et
les cherry on est en retard en banque et
accueillir andreas qui est avec nous tu
es partie des français sont formidables
c'est vraiment des arts merci merci
[Applaudissements]
du coup je me suis aussi fait un petit
peu de télé locale après l'asie mon
choix est fait je suis passé sur un deux
trois ans et donc déjà rien qu'au nom on
sait qu'on va passer un bon moment
1 2 3 dans c'est vrai alors c'est une
émission de danse qui est très connu
dans le milieu de la télé locale
du coup l'animateur en a profité pour
lancer sa célèbre danse de la cie enfin
pas si célèbre que ça quand on regarde
la tête de la dame au deuxième rang
monde sur la piste avec tous les invités
sébastien perrin manu blanche et cédric
deprez dernière poyard jérôme richard
c'est la danse de la cie 11185 n'était
pas trop le nord avec les drôles ici
chercher le guérisseur et grâce à cette
émission du coup j'ai pu découvrir quel
serait le tube de l'été prochain et ce
sera pas david guetta ni les black eyed
peas notre charia un bébé avec sa wii
knee ray charles hamelin nakamura comme
dirait nikos non ce sera ce sera cédric
deprez et sa chanson poignante sur les
frites au passage regardez bien les
siennes au premier rang on sent que
c'est son moment et frites les frites
les frites et oui dans nos rangs même
les frites serré des prêts non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on va papa
comment
j'adore au palais assez rigolé on
m'avait prévenu on m'avait dit fais
attention avec les frites ça va partir à
tout moment et le k1
du coup après ça je suis passé sur comme
comme tv la télé locale de lyon je suis
sûr qu'on va sortir une bague rôle ou
alesi a n'ont même pas serré on a tous
la frime mais j'en ai je lu en elle
comme dans un manuscrit ouvert ma
pyrénées plus loin comme ça originaire
si oui enfin ça c'est sûr comme tv donc
comme tv la télé locale de lyon moi
j'aime bien alors j'aurais dû vous
montrer c'est pas vrai ça j'aurais dû
vous montrer un bulletin météo
malheureusement il n'avait pas de
présentatrice météo jeux que vous n'avez
pas de météo
mais l'animateur a eu une idée pour que
vous puissiez quand même connaître la
météo il est très sérieux la météo de
l'yonne
et puis si vous ne savez pas trop
comment savoir quel temps il va faire le
matin vous vous réveillez vous ouvrez le
volet la gema météo en direct à l'époque
où celui qui suit au revoir
[Applaudissements]
il doit pas des présentatrices météo
mais si on a une fenêtre on peut se
débrouiller excellents joueurs pressés
avec j'ai une vie de déglingo hier soir
je me suis regardé le prime sur tf6
c'était un truc sur les familles
nombreuses donc dans la séquence qui
suit vous allez voir un père de famille
n'ai pas regardé le prime de tpm paie
pas fini très tard oui si je les
regardais ça c est justement dans cette
séquence le père de famille explique
doubiens le prénom de ses enfants et ça
fait plaisir de voir qu'il vit vraiment
de belles histoires familiales ensemble
on fait lycée ma belle-mère qui va
donner le prénom de son chapeau trop vis
des banques la vue sur ma console flavie
flament a prédit loubat sétois il avait
regardé l'île de la tentation qui est
allemande a tous voila la tentation bien
qu'on se dit que s'il avait regardé
secret story aurait pu appeler leurs
enfants la voix et après ça je suis
resté sur cette émission on a fait la
découverte d'une autre famille et dans
ce clan tout le monde est vraiment
content de faire partie de la famille
sauf un enfant dans son regard on sent
qu'il n'est pas encore trop à sa place
et pas comme un ouf non les heureux
parents de johanna six ans d'eileen
maria trois ans isaac deux ans et le
petit dernier michael
[Applaudissements]
il y aura sera comme vous devez le
rasseoir
bon après ça je suis passé sur mtv la
chaîne musicale ouais mais pas qu'eux
ils ont aussi de la télé réalité je suis
tombé sur jean richard la télé réalité
anglaise un peu trash alors avant de
regarder ce programme il faut mettre un
préservatif sinon vous pouvez choper
quelque chose en fait attention je vais
vous préparé le petit déj d'avancé sur
metz [ __ ] je suis désolé je voulais
pas mais elle était sous mon pied énorme
toi j'ai juste dû 40,2 à doit faire au
moins 10 43 vraiment un truc alors c'est
je pense un travail
il pose une question en fait et il dit à
quelqu'un qui va poser une question fait
il en pose complètement une autre c'est
d'une cocasserie ces moments il a pensé
à ça mais j'ai quand il ya un génie je
peux vous dire est à 1 fermez vos
gueules
du coup je préviens la régie que ce sera
le magnéto suivant ce sera le micro
trottoir comme vous l'avez bien expliqué
je vais dans la rue poser dans leur gare
oui ça qui te dit version le sait
d'accord très bien merci aux chats du
coup je vais dans la rue poser des
questions aux français sur les sujets
qui les intéressent peu au dernier
moment je change la question pour un
sujet qui m'intéresse moi et ça crée des
petits malaises quoi explique votre
opposé méditer sur son gilet jaune photo
n'y a pas de souci comment vous appelez
laurent l'europe
je suis avec laurent laurent qui
regardent du porno sur son téléphone et
transport
vous êtes au courant que manifestation
répondre oui merci beaucoup je suis avec
abigail avec gail qui sort de garde à
vue car il s'est fait attraper à
dessiner des tops sont les murs à l'aide
de ce marqueur la regarder je suis avec
williams williams qui concerne
couramment du porno sur son téléphone
portable à l'état de concept après des
manifestations de gilet jaune
ouais ça dérange pas parce que je suis
avec jules jus qui a décidé de partager
avec nous son lourd secret celui de
porter les strings pour un peu on est
comme anti d'ordinn regarde ça n'apporte
pas à te quant aux manifestations des
gilet jaune cet après midi ouais ouais
ça vous dérangerait pas
je suis avec rabbi ai dit qu'ils ont
décidé de partager avec nous leurs
lourds secrets celui de porter les
strings pour homme quoi est-ce qu'on est
à l'aise avec évidemment je suis avec
alan et bilel qui ceux qui sont
représentants d'associations les mdp de
paris des micro pénis de paris ouais
une manifestation ça vous dérangerait
répondre à ça parce que là je tenir ça
se paye merci beaucoup je suis avec
francis francis qui sort de garde à vue
car il s'est fait attraper à dessiner
des sexes sur ces faux nom
je veux pas je veux pas qu'est ce que
c'est que ce bazar work and the papas
c'est pas du tout cas merci andré hatz
exceptionnel
[Applaudissements]